salut aujourd'hui je devais vous donner
les résultats de l'expérience mentale
moutons chèvres
en fait je vous ferai cette vidéo la
lundi pourquoi pas ce qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose d'incroyable aujourd'hui
et il fallait absolument que je vous en
parle
petite parenthèse également j'ai vu que
pierre avait son nouveau compteur lui
aussi je crois qu'il ya une mode des
compteurs qui commence à se lancer à la
différence que moi je n'ai pas pris
cette pelote pour mettre les chiffres
puisque ça ça vaut pour l'un millions
d'abonnés on y est clairement pas pour
mais c'est pas le sujet de la vidéo le
sujet de la vidéo c'est ce petit trophée
que vous voyez là bas ici je vous emmène
le voir mise à jour
alors ici c'est donc le trophée que j'ai
reçus pour les cent mille abonnés voilà
le play oberli car les 5000 youtube
c'était super ou vous de le recevoir que
les reçus lors du meeting que j'ai fait
le 12 octobre dernier au youtube space
appareils et c'est eux qui se sont
occupés de la voir je me suis est ce que
c'est possible d'accueil où tu bois qui
google ces terres que au bout d'un
moment au bout de huit semaines je crois
j'ai eu une petite barbe bleue on me
demandait mon adresse sur youtube
donc je les remplis et j'ai reçu un
petit collier aujourd'hui donc là bas
vous pouvez le voir il y a le trophée
est ici il ya la boîte et si on ouvre la
boîte on s'aperçoit qu'à l'intérieur il
ya la lettre nous l'être humain félicite
merci beaucoup c'est très gentil suzanne
tout suzanne suzanne je ne souhaite pas
prononcer votre nom de famille excusez
moi une jolie mousse protectrice et sous
cette mousse protéomique donc à un
trophée tesson mille abonnés que je vais
sortir tout de suite le découvrir vous
en ai jamais vu d'aussi près
un magnifique trophée voilà avec les
félicitations et hélas là vous vous
dites forcément on n'a pas vu encore les
deux trophées en même temps au même
endroit donc si ça se trouve il en train
de nous faire une vidéo complètement
plus d'un clic il n'a pas du tout les
deux trophées
alors je vais le
posez ici je vais aller chercher le
deuxième voilà je les jeux les deux
cachets alors attention
est ce que cette vidéo est un fake ou
pas est-ce que j'ai vraiment deux
trophées ou pas eh bien vous dit j'ai
trop fait pardon youtube
pardon youtube ça a été un petit
problème dans votre système en interne
et je voulais pas faire ça gênait de
trouver du coup je me dis aussi comme
j'ai passé les 300 mille abonnés à ce
que je vais avoir un troisième trophée
pour les cent mille abonnés ou pas c'est
une question comme ça et après si un
jour j'en ai dit je voulais change des
10 contre le trophée du million faire ça
alors oui comme je vous disais on voit
de plus en plus de compteurs comme le
mien dans les vidéos sur youtube mais je
suis pas sûr qu'on voit de plus en plus
de trophées dans les vidéos youtube mais
dans les miennes celles qui sont faits
ici chez moi il y aura les deux partants
youtube voilà on est on est clairement
sur une vidéo qui n'a rien à voir avec
le cheveu d'habitude mais je trouvais ça
important de partager ce moment là avec
vous maintenant je vais y aller parce
que ce soir je fais une représentation
au trianon soutiennent chaud à brignoles
c'est déjà complet la semaine prochaine
avec kiss en provence il reste vingt
places en tout sur les cinq jours en
février je serai également à toulon à
grenoble et à versailles versailles ce
sera la date la plus proche de paris
sur ces six mois de tournée et puis il
ya tout le reste des dates de tournée
sur le site dont le lien est dans la
description
allez je vous donne rendez-vous lundi
lundi matin on a dit soir peut-être plus
lundi soir pour les résultats de
l'expérience mental c'est peut-être
mieux de voir celle soir dit moi pareil
dans les commentaires si vous préfère
que ce soit le matin ou le soir
peut-être que je vais mettre un petit
sondage là quelque part au-dessus soyez
très attentifs
bon si le fait d'avoir réussi à voir
deux trophées ça vous a fait marrer
n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en
l'air et de vous abonner et rendez vous
lundi matin ou soir pour enfin le
résultat de l'expérience mentale les
résultats sont un peu couche à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]